ah just a which here and there mostly
it's a lot of scrubbing and scouring and
sweeping lots and lots sweeping dizzy
just wouldn't be dizzy without you and a
Cathcart we couldn't imagine anyone else
trying to fill her VK boots
you brought a fun and quirky energy to
disease character so we're not at all
surprised that she's one of our favorite
vks we can't wait to see you reprise her
role as Kitty in to all the boys PS I
still love you
but in the meantime we're going to find
out a little bit more about your girl
dizzy Jermaine dizzy Jermaine is one of
the coolest kids from the Isle but a lot
about her remains a mystery watch until
the end to find out who Disney's father
is here's a clue he's very handsome
so as soon as you get to Oregon you have
to try ice cream and go swimming I can
take her the enchanted Lake all about
dizzy she may be from the Isle of the
loss but she found her passion from a
very young age much like Evie dizzy is a
staple in the fashion industry and she
lives to collaborate you might be asking
yourself how can someone as sweet as
dizzy have been raised by villains
well you and us both somehow dizzy grew
up to be the exact opposite of her
family but we're not complaining as it
turns out Dizzy's grandmother Lady
Tremaine put her to work at the curl up
and die beauty salon from a young age
undoubtedly sparking disease desire to
become a fashionista
although dizzy might not be anything
like her family she is who she is
because of them where is Dizzy's mom we
first meet dizzy in descendants - when
now comes knocking for a full blown
makeover Dizzy's mother is Gisela
Tremaine one of Cinderella's wicked
stepsisters she's proven herself to be
vain mean and everything in between so
we're not surprised that she wound up on
the Isle oddly enough we never get to
see Drizella in The Descendants movies
and dizzy barely ever talks about her so
where is she and why isn't she in the
picture well it turns out dizzy isn't an
only child she has six other sisters
that need taking care of so it makes
sense that
dizzi would spend most of her time with
her grandmother working to make extra
money and pursuing her passions at the
same time Gisela isn't an absent mother
she's a busy one dizzy was raised by her
grandmother lady tremaine may have
treated her stepdaughter Cinderella in
the most terrible way but when it comes
to dizzy she has a soft spot tour she
gets dizzy to do maintenance in her hair
salon but she also gives her a platform
to practice her vocations at first
glance Lady Tremaine is a spiteful and
evil woman with a hidden agenda but once
you take a closer look you realize that
she has as many layers as Shrek the Isle
of the lost has transformed her into a
caring grandma yes everything are you
sure I'm sure granny oh really why else
would she have smiled when dizzy hugged
her goodbye in descendants three lady
tremaine practically raised dizzy
single-handedly and she's very proud of
her
Anastasia and Anthony Germain so now
that we know that Gisela isn't glued to
Dizzy's side let's find out what her
mother's twin sister anastasi Germain is
up to unlike Gisela Anastasia only has
one child and his name is Anthony but
Anastasia isn't supposed to be on the
Isle since she did turn good in the
second and third Cinderella movies so
we're guessing that Anastasia is more
than a little bitter because she wound
up on the Isle anyway her son Anthony is
16 years old and appears in novels like
the Isle of lost and returned to the
Isle of the Lost
despite playing a significant role in
the books Anthony was cut out from the
film's Cinderella and Chad charming
before the barrier was taken down in d3
Disney's extended family lived happily
ever after on the other side of the
water Cinderella is dizzy step and
making Chad charming her stuffed cousin
- so you would think that Chad would
welcome dizzy with open arms once she
crossed over to Aragon that just isn't
Chad's style
it looks like dizzy doesn't have a
relationship with her step family which
makes sense considering that they never
met before but we're sure does he would
love to meet Cinderella and show her
that not all the Jermaine's have a
hidden agenda the family she chooses
it's old news that VK
don't have the best relationships with
their parents and siblings which is why
most BK's choose a family of their own
dizzi designed the little hats that
celia Fassler proudly wears which is how
celia and dizzy became such good friends
dizzy may already have six sisters but
clearly she sees Evie as her big and
awesome sister too dizzy loves her
family but she's extremely loyal and
protective when it comes to her friends
she'll do just about anything for the
core for while getting up to no good
with her best pal Celia who is Dizzy's
dad we told you he was handsome and we
weren't joking around but he's also a
wicked villain who will do just about
anything to become a king even if that
means freezing a few hearts along the
way Dizzy's father is none other than
Hans from the Southern Isles
we love this theory because it checks
out Hans has red hair and is known for
being the youngest and smallest out of
all his siblings he was tormented by his
siblings while growing up which is
something that dizzy has in common
Dizzy's dad would have wanted to have a
big family because he came from one
Dizzy's also on the small side has
reddish hair and is teased by her family
and put to work just like Hans what do
you guys think is Hans Dizzy's father
sound off in the comments everything you
need to know about dizzy Jermaine's
family thanks for watching hit that
subscribe button if you love all things
Disney and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
on the things
[Music]